john stossel is a time to abolish the
fda
uh unethical to deny americans of
life-saving drugs this is a real clear
politics story thousands of people are
weak
per week continue to die from cover 19
yet america's fda stops people from
taking drugs that might save lives john
stossel weighs in stossel i'm surprised
that we haven't heard more about new
drugs that may covet less of a threat
one drug reduced the risk of health
death or hospitalization by 89 in trials
the media probably doesn't report on
them much because you and i aren't
permitted to take them the fda
makes everyone wait until the drugs meet
the urgent agencies rigorous standards
but while we wait thousands die abolish
the fda
that's your position yes they've
justified
having the right to
ban drugs from thalidomide from
many many years ago when this bad drug
got on the market and hurt people
and that's happened sometimes
but
when they and by the way this drug now
is available they did speed the process
at least
but when they say this new drug will
save 10 000 lives a year
and it takes 10 years to get it approved
that means they killed 10 000 people
last year and the year before but they
don't count in the media reporting or in
government thinking yeah this has been
going on for generations i mean multiple
generations where people have gone to
europe or other countries where
their equivalent of the fda is much more
expeditious in getting these drugs to
the pipeline so if you again if you have
the means then you go to another country
and you get the drug that you know that
you need that's going to save your life
if you don't have the means in your
america you die
and it's not like if you abolish the fda
everybody's going to take bad drugs and
die
it's
new things will appear consumer right
consumer reports underwriters
laboratories
some people will get suckered and will
die and we'll learn from that and in the
long run more people will live
so you are in the school of thought of
trust 99 of people to make the decisions
for themselves it goes back to that same
thing it's our body and if i'm dying
shouldn't i get to try some new drug
as opposed to waiting for a broken
bureaucracy to to deliver a decade later
current system doesn't trust you to make
the right decision for yourself
right in many areas so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]